[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer la soirée dans les Yvelines
avec au programme de l'actualité des
infos pratiques et des idées de sortie
voici le programme de ce 22 février
le Salon de l'Agriculture ouvre ses
portes samedi c'est jusqu'au 5 mars à
Paris Porte de Versailles quelques
yvelinois seront présents dans les
allées de cet événement l'un des plus
populaires de France parmi eux l'huile
riz de la plaine de Versailles basé à
ben elle a fédéré notamment 30
producteurs du département pour produire
huile lentilles ou encore farine son
fondateur Christian Hubert et notre
invité pas de congé d'hiver pour
parcoursup jusqu'au 9 mars les lycéens
étudiants sont invités à formuler leurs
vœux sur la plateforme d'orientation
c'est dans ce cadre que dans le 7 8 nous
vous proposons tous les mercredis la
découverte d'une formation du territoire
ce soir focus sur le but Bachelor
universitaire de technologie en
technique de commercialisation il est
dispensé à l'IUT de Vélizy Rambouillet à
ta chaîne université Versailles
Saint-Quentin comment se déroule la
formation comment y entrer nous
répondrons à ces questions avec des
étudiants et notre journaliste Régine
Radès
et puis c'est un incontournable des
vacances ou même de plus en plus dans
votre quotidien avec près de 3 millions
de ventes en 2021 le vélo est l'un des
transports les plus populaires en France
pour le réparer à moindre frais elle
l'association vicyclette propose des
ateliers à Montigny-le-Bretonneux à
notre journaliste Julien Leroy a pu
s'essayer à la réparation du câble de
frein
et puis au long de tout au long de cette
émission des invités autour de la table
sur ma droite Charles Rodwell bonsoir
bonsoir merci pour votre invitation
d'être avec nous député de la première
circonscription des Yvelines députés
renaissants vous êtes également un
membre de la commission des affaires
économiques à l'Assemblée nationale et
vous avez été très récemment le corps à
porteur d'une mission parlementaire sur
les dispositifs de soutien à l'export et
à l'attractivité économique en quelques
mots juste pour poser le sujet de quoi
s'agit-il en fait en quelques mots cette
mission servait à contribuer à répondre
à un paradoxe qui est en France c'est
qu'on a un déficit commercial qui est le
plus important depuis des années
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que la France elle importe plus qu'elle
n’importe donc ça veut dire qu'elle
s'appauvrit plus qu'elle ne s'enrichit
vis-à-vis de d'autres pays des pays
étrangers il faut qu'on y trouve des
solutions pour réduire ce déficit de
commercial et en même temps on n'a
jamais eu autant d'entreprises qui
exportent en France on n'a jamais été
aussi attractif pour des investisseurs
donc des gens qui disent qui ont
confiance dans notre pays qui ont
confiance dans les ressorts de notre
économie et qui du coup viennent
investir en France pour stimuler
l'industrie c'est un enjeu qui est hyper
important pour notre pays c'est aussi un
enjeu très important pour notre
département les Yvelines et dans ce
cadre les entreprises yvinoises et les
élus yvinois ont un enjeu majeur et une
responsabilité dans ce dans ce domaine
pourquoi parce qu'on est à la fois un
département qui est extrêmement
dynamique 22 000 entreprises créées rien
qu'en 2022 dans les Yvelines et en même
temps rien que les Yvelines c'est 10
milliards d'euros de déficit commercial
ça veut dire que rien que les Yvelines
c'est 10 milliards d'euros
d'importations en plus que d'exportation
donc avec vous l'avez dit aussi des
répercussions dans les Yvelines on aura
l'occasion d'en parler sans un instant
et vous parliez de ce paradoxe autour
notamment de ce déficit commercial qui
est record même en France on en parlera
tout à l'heure dans cette édition en
face de vous je le disais dans les
titres il y a Christian Hubert bonsoir
fondateur de l'huile riz de la de
Versailles alors pour la première fois
vous allez participer au Salon de
l'Agriculture qui s'ouvre à Paris ce
week-end vous êtes installé à Beynes et
donc l'huile riz de la plaine de
Versailles juste aussi pour avoir
quelques mots d'introduction qu'est-ce
que c'est l'huile de la plaine au
Versailles
est un regroupement de producteurs et
donc on valorise en transforme nos
produits donc le blé l'orge les
lentilles et donc on les transforme pour
les rendre consommables directement par
nos voisins donc les lentilles on le
retrouve pour les consommer en entrée ou
un plat du jour le colza on l'écrase
pour faire de l'huile et le blé on
écrase également pour faire de la farine
on en tient un peu plus tout à l'heure
juste à côté de vous Céline Charles de
la rédaction de tvse 118 bonsoir Céline
pour votre petite chronique autour des
sorties cinéma de la semaine les sorties
à ne pas manquer cette semaine et on va
forcément parler j'imagine du dernier né
de Spielberg aujourd'hui bien sûr on ne
peut pas louper ça on va pas passer à
côté du nouveau film de Steven Spielberg
mais on parlera aussi d'une adaptation
autobiographique d'un documentaire
animalier sur les baleines ce sera tout
à l'heure et comme chaque mercredi aussi
le coup de cœur du pro un cinéma pour
avoir et bien découvrir ou redécouvrir
un classique du cinéma ce soir Gautier
Bas-Rhin nous présentera docteur patch
c'est un film qui l'a sélectionné pour
nous à suivre également dans un instant
à les informations du jour un zoom aussi
sur les institutions européennes avec
nos confrères de radio sensation mais
avant de démarrer ce programme copieux
on va jeter un petit coup d'oeil à la
météo de demain
de la grisaille demain matin dans les
Yvelines il fera 7 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie 6° à Houdan et
Versailles c'est un peu plus doux dans
le sud du département avec 8 degrés à
Rambouillet à Rambouillet ou quelques
gouttes de pluie sont attendus dans
l'après-midi au contraire du reste du
territoire où l'on pouvait pourrait
apercevoir quelques éclaircies côté
température 9 degrés sur la partie
centrée sud des Yvelines 10 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie ce jeudi 23 février
c'est la Saint Lazare le point à présent
dans le 7 8 sur du jour dans les
Yvelines et c'est avec Régine radesh
[Musique]
à la suite des opérations de recherche
des victimes des cismes en Turquie et en
Syrie des sapeurs sauveteurs et des
sapeurs-pompiers des Yvelines se sont
rendus ce matin au kogique le centre
opérationnel de gestion
interministérielle des crises ils ont
été reçus par le directeur général de la
Sécurité civile pour un retour
d'expérience
suite au révélations liée à la vente aux
enchères des meubles du château de
Grignon le procureur général a saisi la
Cour des comptes en vue de l'ouverture
d'une instruction contentieuse il
décidera si la faire fera l'objet d'un
classement ou d'un renvoi devant la
chambre du contentieux en sport arthurin
dirknech le joueur de tennis originaire
de Saint-Germain-en-Laye a perdu ce
mardi 6 3 6 4 contre le joueur Leandro
riez dit au premier tour du tournoi de
Marseille il retombe donc à la 72e place
mondiale ce mercredi 22 février marque
la journée mondiale du scoutisme le
département des Yvelines compte 20 000
scouts ce qui en fait le département
numéro 1 en France tout mouvement
confondus parmi les villes où on trouve
le plus d'effectif Saint-Germain-en-Laye
Versailles Rambouillet et
Montfort-l'Amaury
jusqu'au 21 avril les apprentis du
cfa-cma 78 de Versailles propose une
coupe gratuite aux étudiants et aux
personnels de l'université Versailles
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines l'objectif
permettre aux apprentis de travailler
sur clientèle et prestations se
déroulent sous le contrôle d'un
professeur
et comme d'habitude si vous voyez une
information qui vous fait réagir dans le
département n'hésitez pas à le dire sur
les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 78 news je le disais en début de
cette nuit nous avons avec nous Charles
rudwell qui est député de la première
circonscription des Yvelines on va
parler avec vous de ce rapport à cette
mission parlementaire autour de l'export
et de l'attractivité économique
l'actualité récente forcément aussi pour
pour démarrer c'est débats qui sont
achevés vendredi autour de la réforme
des retraites à l'Assemblée nationale le
texte qui va être débattu désormais
océan première lecture deux semaines de
débat on peut le dire pour le moins
houleuse avec beaucoup de violences on a
vu beaucoup de violence dans cette
émission sans discussion aussi autour de
cet article phare de la réforme qui est
l'article 7 qui est bien fait ce report
de l'âge légal à 64 ans les guêpe de
départ à la retraite du coup le bilan il
est plutôt négatif après ces deux
semaines de débat à durée nationale qui
a le bilan voudrait c'est moi je
regrette qu'on ne soit pas allé au bout
du texte notamment au bout de cet
article l'article 7 on a été empêché par
un blocage
de débat parlementaire par une
obstruction parlementaire de la part de
collègues si vous voulez je veux pas
revenir sur toutes les polémiques qui a
eu ces dernières semaines on les a tous
vu chacun d'entre nous moi ce que je
regrette c'est que du fait de la
majorité relative depuis plusieurs mois
la somme de la nationale revient un peu
sous le coup des projecteurs et les
débats que l'on a à la fois les médias
vous les journalistes mais aussi chaque
citoyen disent on re-regarde une partie
des débats parlementaires et depuis le
début de la législature je crois qu'on a
quand même montré sur un certain nombre
de textes très important la protection
sanitaire le pouvoir d'achat l'assurance
chômage les énergies renouvelables qu'on
a su débattre en étant souvent en
désaccord en désaccord parfois
importants mais en trouvant des
majorités en trouvant du consensus
et le spectacle qui a été celui de
l'Assemblée nationale pendant la réforme
des retraites pendant le texte qu'on a
étudié n'a absolument pas montré cela et
à montrer tout l'inverse moi je pense
que c'est la responsabilité d'une part
de nos collègues sur le sujet mais je
pense qu'on a une responsabilité tous
collective de retrouver la sérénité
qu'on a eu dans le débat depuis le début
du quinquennat au service en fait tout
simplement des Français qui nous ont
élus alors c'est un moment confus à
l'Assemblée nationale alors que dans le
même temps les manifestations sont
plutôt bien déroulées dans la rue pas
d'incident à remonter c'est monter à
plus de 2,5 millions de manifestants
selon la CGT les syndicats qui appellent
à une nouvelle journée de mobilisation
une grande journée de mobilisation le 7
mars prochain comment avancer justement
dans cette séquence alors qu'il y a
quand même une contestation autour de ce
projet il y a un récent sondage un livre
sosteria qui faisait têtard quand même
de 64% de Français qui seraient opposés
à ce texte de la réforme des retraites
moi je souhaiterais juste revenir sur le
rôle que les syndicats ont joué et le
rendre un hommage moi je suis coupable à
la réforme des retraites une bonne
partie des syndicats la CFDT la CGT
Force ouvrière en tête ils sont opposés
mais je veux vraiment leur rendre
hommage sur la manière dont elles ont
mené les manifestations dans le calme
dans la sérénité sont des bords malgré
la radicalisation qu'appelait certains
mouvements politiques en France je pense
notamment à l'extrême gauche ils ne sont
pas tombés dans ce piège ils ont fait
entendre leur voix en manifestants dans
le calme la deuxième chose pour laquelle
je voudrais le rendre hommage c'est la
concertation le dialogue n'a jamais été
rompu entre le gouvernement et les
syndicats et si on a pu améliorer le
texte sur la pénibilité sur les
carrières dites hachées c'est un mot que
je n'aime pas mais qui décrit une
réalité sur la prise en compte du droit
des femmes sur la prise en compte des
carrières longues c'est en grande partie
grâce au rôle que les syndicats ont joué
à la fois dans la manifestation mais
aussi dans la concertation qui est dans
le gouvernement encore une fois je vous
le répète je ne partage pas leur avis
mais je le rends cet hommage qui je
crois participe à une sérénité autour de
ce débat j'imagine Christian Aubert vous
qui est faite partie du monde agricole
qu'on regarde aussi cette séquence avec
intérêt cette séquence autour de la
réforme des retraites oui on regarde ça
d'assez loin puisque finalement le
meilleur agricole travaille longtemps
sans forcément regarder là je vais
départ de retraite mais oui alors après
aussi la retraite à l'école est une des
plus faibles donc finalement les acteurs
cotisent quand même travail dur toute
leur année et finalement on arrive dans
le fameux minima nécessaire donc il y a
eu des pistes mais bon il y a peut-être
encore un petit travail à faire sur le
minimum vieillesse alors on date de loin
mais
je partage totalement votre avis
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a décidé la
suppression des régimes spéciaux et pour
le coup c'est une partie du texte qu'on
a voté à l'assemblée mais tout
simplement parce que il y a certaines
professions pour lesquelles le régime
est structuellement déficitaire
aujourd'hui il y a plus d'agriculteurs à
la retraite que d'agriculteur qui
travaillent et donc si le régime
dépendait uniquement des agriculteurs il
faudrait vous demander de payer des
cotisations absolument astronomiques ou
alors il faudrait demander aux
agriculteurs à la retraite d'avoir une
pension encore plus faible nous l'idée
qu'on défend du régime des retraites
c'est dire qu'on a un régime général qui
permet à tous d'avoir un minimum
vieillesse un minimum retraite à
carrière complète à au minimum 1200
euros et pour cela lançons des
travailleurs quel que soit leur
profession doivent contribuer à ce
régime général pour permettre à tout le
monde d'avoir un minimum retraite c'est
l'idée de la réforme que je défends et
je comprends qu'on soit pas d'accord le
débat parlementaire doit exister pour ça
j'espère qu'il redeviendra plus serein
pour qu'on puisse débattre de cette
question le texte maintenant est très
examiné par par les sénateurs alors
au-delà des travaux parlementaires sur
la réforme des retraites vous avez
travaillé récemment je le disais tout à
l'heure Charles Rodwell sur les
dispositifs de soutien à l'export et à
la tractivité économique et vous avez
rendu vos conclusions tout récemment
puisque c'était à la à la fin janvier
alors c'est une mission parlementaire
vous avez confié avec une autre députée
députée de l'opposition et de la France
insoumise Sofia à chikiru bah comment ça
s'est passé justement la collaboration
écoutez elle sait très bien passer
justement parce qu'on a des avis
divergents et c'est ça qui est
merveilleux dans le travail
parlementaire c'est que hors champ des
caméras et or émissaire il y a un vrai
travail approfondi qui se fait entre les
parlementaires qui ont des avis
totalement différents ce fichier chikiru
est membre du groupe de la France
insoumise je suis membre du groupe
Renaissance et pourtant 90% des
propositions que nous avons faites nous
avons fait des propositions en commun on
a des désaccords majeurs sur la
fiscalité sur les investissements
étrangers en France mais on a aussi
trouvé des points d'accord pourquoi
parce que comment se mène une mission
parlementaire elle se mène en
auditionnant les sachants les services
de l'État les élus locaux les
collectivités locales les entreprises et
leurs salariés à travers les fédérations
interprofessionnelles les entreprises
yvelinoises on a interrogé des dizaines
et des dizaines surprise de la
circonscription à la fois par des
échanges informels par un vrai une vraie
table ronde qu'on a formé à l'Assemblée
nationale ce que j'allais vous demander
qu'est-ce qu'une mission parlementaire
c'est des auditions finalement sur un
sujet on interroge les sachants sur un
sujet on initiait sur un sujet en disant
il faut trouver des solutions sur ce
sujet on interroge l'ensemble des partis
prenantes les acteurs publics les
acteurs privés les acteurs nationaux les
acteurs locaux on les interroge sur les
solutions que eux rencontrent
concrètement dans leur vie quotidienne
et ensuite nous regardons ensemble nous
les parlementaires comment est-ce qu'on
peut amender la loi comment est-ce qu'on
peut conseiller le gouvernement pour
faire voler une partie de l'action au
service des entreprises le gouvernement
et les acteurs locaux on a visité une
entreprise qui s'appelle prodways à
Montigny une pépite une pépite
industrielle et on l'a visité avec qui
avec le sous-préfieux développement
économique avec le président de la
Chambre de commerce et d'industrie
Guillaume quiraux avec le président
l'agglomération Jean-Michel fourgus et
sa directrice de développement
économique avec le maire de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux Laurent mercière
pourquoi les collectivement mais tout
simplement parce que chaque acteur que
je viens de citer un rôle clé à jouer
pour soutenir nos entreprises à l'export
et pour soutenir la réindustrialisation
de chaque département en France et c'est
ce travail collectif en commun c'est par
ce travail qu'on y arrivera le
parlementaire tout seul il peut rien
faire donc c'est un travail collectif
pour mener à bien cette mission qui part
on lisait d'un constat un paradoxe avec
ce déficit commercial record en France
un 154 milliards d'euros alors même que
la France a un reste le pays européen le
plus attractif pour les investissements
étrangers et du coup qu'est-ce que vous
avez constaté sur le terrain il y a
quand même une audition auprès d'une
trentaine d'entreprises qu'est-ce qu'il
en est ressorté est-ce que les
dispositifs fonctionnent bien est-ce
qu'il faut aller plus loin peut-être
dans leur fonctionnement qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous en avez conclu et
qu'est-ce que vous avez pu observer la
principale conclusion qu'on a tiré sur
le terrain c'est que l'export
exporter nos produits à l'étranger doit
s'inscrire au cœur de notre stratégie
industrielle depuis 5 ans on a lancé un
syndrome de politique pour
réindustrialiser notre pays donc
reproduire en France dans tous les
domaines que ce soit dans le secteur
agroalimentaire et agricole que soit
dans le secteur de l'automobile que ce
soit dans le secteur de l'industrie
lourde et l'autre technologie du
nucléaire de de l'aéronautique et
d'autres mais pour pouvoir relancer
l'export il faut que au bout de la
chaîne on propose à nos entreprises de
vendre leurs produits à l'étranger et
qu'au début de la chaîne on propose à
des investisseurs étrangers de venir en
France et de continuer à investir dans
nos entreprises en faisant bien
attention que ces investissements ne
viennent pas à l'encon de nos intérêts
nationaux c'est pour ça qu'il faut
renforcer les contrôles mais comment
est-ce qu'on fait à la fois par la loi
mais aussi départements par département
ville parvine commune par commune
entreprise par entreprise c'est la
raison pour laquelle le département et
les communes ont un rôle clé à jouer
dans le domaine je parlais tout à
l'heure des Yvelines l'enjeu national
l'enjeu français c'est en enjeu
yvelinois on appelle un paradoxe de sens
département que il y a jamais eu autant
de création d'entreprises 22000
entreprises créées en 2022 et en même
temps rien que le département des
Yvelines c'est 10 milliards d'euros de
déficit commercial donc tout le travail
que font les conseils départementaux les
présidents d'intercaux les maires les
parlementaires quand on se saisit du
sujet pour soutenir nos entreprises pour
les mettre en lien pour leur permettre
de produire et enfin pour leur permettre
d'exporter c'est comme ça entreprise par
entreprise qu'on va pouvoir répondre à
cet enjeu c'est la conviction que j'ai
et c'est la conviction que je crois
partage macora porteur sur la mission
malgré nos désaccord politique nationaux
et très rapidement la suite maintenant
est-ce que ça pourrait conduire à des
évolutions concrètes on a fait un
certain nombre de propositions 30
propositions dans le projet qui vont de
mesures législatives jusqu'à des
propositions d'expérimentation donc des
mécanismes qu'on voudrait tester moi
j'aimerais que les Yvelines soient en
département test sur le sujet en tout
cas c'est les échanges que nous avons
aujourd'hui pour porter ses propositions
et pour les mettre en oeuvre alors dans
l'actualité il y a aussi une autre
mesure on parle d'un tout autre sujet
par le ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald
Darmanin c'est la suppression des 12
points sur le permis de conduire pour
les personnes qui prennent le volant
sous emprise de drogue ou d'alcool le
débat et sur la table il est revenu sur
la table avec le grave accident qui est
impliqué à l'humoriste Pierre Palmade il
y a quelques jours alors dans l'émission
PAF elle l'avocat au Barreau de
Versailles Geoffrey Meyer et revenu sur
sur cette mesure sur cette annonce pour
lui elle existe déjà cette mesure n'est
pas forcément
utile on écoute Geoffrey Meyer tout de
suite ce que veut faire Gérald Darmanin
c'est générer une automaticité sur le
retrait du permis de conduire
l'invalidation pour des faux de points
dans l'hypothèse ou une personne aurait
conduit en étant sous l'emprise de
stupéfiants mais en réalité la loi
prévoit déjà cette possibilité lorsque
vous êtes lorsque vous êtes contrôlé
après avoir conduit sous l'emprise de
stupéfiants vous êtes donc passible
d'une comparution devant le tribal
correctionnel et vous avez aussi la
possibilité de faire l'objet d'une
rétention de votre permis de conduire
par décision préfectorale donc cette
décision est ce dispositif existe déjà
le tribunal correctionnel lorsqu'il est
saisi par le procureur de la République
après que une personne ait été contrôlée
en ayant conduit après avoir consommé
des stupéfiants peut tout à fait
prononcer une annulation du permis de
conduire on est à livrer en état
d'ivresse aussi donc cette mesure existe
déjà donc je pense que Gérald Darmanin
est en train tranquillement de ce
présidentialiser et il reprend un petit
peu les vieilles recettes qui avaient
fonctionné et surf sur la vague de
l'émotion qui a été générée par
l'accident causé par Pierre Palmade mais
en tout cas cette mesure est à mon avis
de mesure premièrement
inutile sur le plan Judy juridique et
judiciaire parce que les dispositions
existent déjà et que deuxièmement
effectivement
peut s'interroger sur le bien fondé en
matière de société et de santé de de
cette de cette mesure là je suis une
réaction rapide je vous ferai meilleur
dit que ça existe déjà dans le reste
qu'il faut aller plus loin à votre avis
sur ce sujet à des personnes qui
conduisent sous l'emprise de drogue de
d'alcool alors Gérald Darmanin aussi
fait une autre proposition c'est de
supprimer le retrait d'un point au
permis pour les petits excès de vitesse
à ce inférieur ou égal à 5 km/h je ne
partage absolument pas les propos qui
viennent d'être tenus tant sur
l'intention que sur les faits ce
monsieur vient d'exprimer lui-même que
la suppression ou le retrait du permis
était
dépendait d'une décision une gestion
préfectorale ce que propose générale
d'armanin c'est tout simplement que le
retrait soit automatique pourquoi si tu
mesures de justice quand vous prenez la
voiture sous emprise de droite vous êtes
un danger public et vous causer des
dangers de mort
on l'a vu récemment donc il est
parfaitement normal que lorsque vous
prenez votre voiture sous emprise de la
drogue votre permis soit retiré et à
l'inverse le sujet des travailleurs il y
a des millions de Français qui vont
travailler tous les jours en voiture et
qui n'ont pas d'autres choix ce que
propose Gérald Darmanin c'est sert de
les sanctionner lorsqu’un lorsqu'il y a
un excès de vitesse mais de prendre en
compte la situation de chacun dans le
domaine oui il faut les sanctionner
quand il y a un excès de vitesse mais
oui il faut aussi mieux prendre en
compte le fait qu'il y a des millions de
Français qui vont travailler en voiture
tous les jours c'est le sens de la
deuxième mesure qu'il fait quant à la
première il est évident que le retrait
doit être automatique lorsque quelqu'un
est un danger public sur la route merci
Charles Rodwell d'avoir répondu à tous
ces sujets je rappelle que vous êtes le
député de la première circonscription
des unes suivra bien sûr la suite des
événements pour pour ce rapport que et
ses conclusions que vous avez rendu à la
fin janvier autour de l'export et de
l'attractivité économique merci d'avoir
été avec nous un grand merci pour votre
invitation alors ça vous est peut-être
déjà
arriver à avoir des difficultés pour
faire vos démarches en ligne ou encore
rédiger un mail scène et Yvelines
numériques des poids depuis septembre
2021 le dispositif passe numérique dans
les départements des Hauts-de-Seine et
des Yvelines c'est un outil d'inclusion
numérique il permet de lutter contre
l'électronisme les détails de Céline
charge un chéquier d'une valeur de 100
euros à échanger contre une série de 10
heures de formation voilà ce que propose
le Pass numérique sur le principe des
tickets-restaurants il permet au
bénéficiaires de payer totalement ou en
partie des cours numériques auprès de
structures spécialisées on a différents
publics qui sont concernés c'est vrai
qu'il y a de plus en plus ce qu'on
appelle la dématérialisation des
services publics c'est à dire la
l'obligation d'aller sur le site
internet pour faire des démarches
publiques donc il répond vraiment à
destination de trois publics les gens en
difficulté sociale les gens alors là
vous appelez les seniors même si les
seigneurs qui sont très bons pour aller
sur internet et également les personnes
qui ont des difficultés qu'on juste pas
d'outils numériques
déploie le pass numérique dans les
départements des Hauts-de-Seine et des
Yvelines depuis septembre 2021 au centre
socio-culturel yaick Noah à Asnières des
ateliers d'initiation et de
perfectionnement avec des professionnels
sont proposés Anne de Françoise y
prennent part une fois par semaine
j'arrivais à la retraite et que je
savais que j'étais pas du tout
informatique j'allais au bureau chercher
des papiers mais plus qu'on a vu déjà
après le covid 19 que tous les bureaux
sont fermés Françoise tu peux un peu
nous dire à quoi ressemblerait un mot de
passe sécurisé pour la création alors
il faut que ce mot de passe soit composé
de majuscule de chiffres c'est quelque
chose qui est devenu important pour
notre quotidien de pouvoir
savoir
gérer l'informatique aller sur le site
chercher des informations la technique
on nous la donne pas c'est pas une née
et si on n'est pas détenait avec ça j'ai
un pc chez moi j'ai une tablette j'ai un
smartphone mais je bidouille et je il y
a des choses que je ne sais pas faire et
que j'aimerais faire effectuer une
démarche en ligne protéger ses données
personnelles ou encore naviguer sur le
Web les cours ont un seul objectif mené
petit à petit vers l'autonomie là on est
plutôt face à une fracture numérique de
premier degré qui correspond à un non
accès à la formation et une fracture
numérique de second degré qui correspond
à un non accès à l'usage avec beaucoup
de crainte et beaucoup de peur qu'il
faut aussi lever depuis son déploiement
quasiment 200 formations ont été données
en France 13 millions de Français
demeurent encore éloignés du numérique
avant de poursuivre le programme de ce 7
8 quelques nouvelles de cette
information dont nous parlions hier une
barge transportante du nitrate de
calcium a heurté ce lundi soir un pont à
qui enjambe la Seine au niveau de
Triel-sur-Seine une soixantaine de
sapeurs-pompiers dont des plongeurs et
10 engins ont été mobilisés la
préfecture afin d'étape ce mercredi à
18h la suite a été contrôlée et des
prélèvements de l'eau de la scène sont
partis en analyse ce mercredi une barge
de secours est arrivé sur place pour
transporter une grande partie du nitrate
de calcium encore présent dans le bateau
endommagé elle se rendra ensuite vers le
site d'Achères pour la décharger demain
avant de vider les dernières cubes la
nature de l'avarice n'est pas encore
connue voilà ce qu'on pouvait vous dire
avec ces nouvelles informations autour
de cet incident qui est survenu lundi
soir sur la scène et j-3 avant le début
du Salon de la grille culture il s'ouvre
ce samedi sur le site Paris Expo Paris
Porte de Versailles et toute cette
semaine nous ont des focus sur les
représentants yvelinois qui seront sur
place place un rappel pour les Yvelines
sont le deuxième territoire agricole en
Île-de-France les producteurs sont donc
au rendez-vous et ce soir nous avons en
plateau le fondateur de l'huile riz de
la plaine de Versailles c'est Christian
Hubert alors chez les Hubert d'ailleurs
l'agriculture c'est une affaire de
famille ça se transmet de génération en
génération tout à fait donc mes
grands-parents étaient exploitants donc
c'est réalisé de producteurs de grandes
cultures tout comme mes parents et bah
j'ai repris le flambeau avec une
particularité de transformer nos
produits pour ne plus le vendre
justement à l'exportation mais le garder
sur le territoire mais justement je vais
faire une petite transition avec
transition
notre objectif n'est pas de d'exporter
par contre si on prend le cas des
lentilles aujourd'hui les trois quarts
des lentilles viennent du Canada
on les apporte du Canada ce qui est une
aberration totale ce que d'une part on
sait les produits j'en parlerai tout à
l'heure mais d'autre part on apporte un
modèle agricole qu'on ne veut pas c'est
de la déforestation c'est de l'OGM c'est
du glyphosate et ça devient le bout du
monde alors pourquoi les importer du
coup pourquoi parce que c'est peut-être
un peu moins cher et surtout je pense
on sait pas que dans les Yvelines on
peut faire pousser ses plantes et
qu'elle pousse bien et qu'elles sont
bien la cuisson qu'à son bun savoureuse
et finalement il y a rien à voir avec
ses lentilles du Canada ça va continuer
le côté agriculture chez les Hubert vous
essayez de le transmettre aussi oui on
ne force pas mais si la passion est là
chez nos fils pourquoi pas et avec
plaisir mais il y a il y a de quoi faire
et de beaux projets à relever donc ils
sont jeunes mais pourquoi pas alors vous
êtes tourné vous autour de la production
de blé de colza d'orge travailler avec
une trentaine de producteurs de Terry du
territoire on va en parler dans un
instant et vous êtes aussi tourné vers
les légumineuses pour pourquoi ce type
de culture est-il intéressant dans les
Yvelines justement alors comme on disait
avant donc mes grands-parents et mes
parents donc exploités et exploitent
toujours pour mes parents du blé du maïs
de colza de l'orge ce sont les cultures
qu'on maîtrises on sait les faire
pousser sa réussite bien dans nos
notaires depuis maintenant 5 ans j'ai
décidé de lancer la production de
légumineuses pourquoi c'est une nouvelle
famille de culture et de côté
agronomique c'est bien pour le sol plus
il y a de familles différentes mieux
c'est pourquoi il y a moins de
salissements il y a moins de maladies et
donc finalement ça permet de préserver
notre environnement et de préserver nos
notaires à côté il y avait l'attente
sociétale qui demande de plus en plus de
légumineuses et donc finalement les deux
volontés se sont retrouvés et on se dit
on y va et autour de vous avez fédéré
une trentaine de producteurs du
territoire c'est important de fédérer
tout ce monde pourquoi c'est aussi
intéressant de le fédérer travailler
avec plusieurs
ma démarche personnelle sur
l'introduction de nouvelles cultures
d'une nouvelle famille finalement mes
voisins l'avaient aussi après il y avait
le souci comment faire pour le vendre
à proximité il y a le souci de
travailler on va dire on adéquation avec
la manière de faire de chaque producteur
qui sont agriculture biologique de
précision et en tout cas un respect
aussi de votre part de cette manière de
faire c'est capital notre monde
producteur ce sont engagés à produire
sur des méthodes virtuelles pour
l'environnement alors il y a le bio j'en
parle pas parce qu'on en parle
énormément mais il y a tout ce qui est
déjà conversion va être biologique trois
ans compliqué pour les producteurs donc
on les accompagne on valoriser leur
production mais il y a aussi tout ce qui
est avec d'autres conservation des sols
qui est complètement méconnu du grand
public mais qui amène beaucoup de
bienfaits filmer votre environnement
un des exemples c'est on ne tue plus les
vers de terre en travaillant le sol et
on évite finalement que quand il y a des
gros orages toute la bourse se retrouve
dans le salon des voisins donc ça a
beaucoup de vertus même si on utilise
toujours un peu de produits de synthèse
il y a la lecture de précision après
l'acteur certifié il y a les 14000 ans
donc c'est en fait du progrès continu en
environnement il faut partir de notre
groupe voilà donc ce sont que des
producteurs qui font un effort vis-à-vis
de l'environnement et qui se remet en
question et qui essaie de faire de mieux
en mieux et donc on parle de culture de
lentilles de poids de grains production
d'huile de farine bah quelle gamme
justement quel type alors l'objectif
c'est que tout ce qu'on produit sur nos
fermes de grandes cultures des Yvelines
finalement puissent se retrouver sur une
assiette de nos voisins donc le blé on
le transforme en farine pour faire des
gâteaux du pain faire plein de choses
l'orge on l'a fait maltée et après on
l'avant au micro brasseur afin de la
bière pierre de plus en plus apprécié il
y en a de nombreuses microbrasseries sur
le territoire une femme micro une fois
la bien obtenu on récupère des drêches
donc finalement c'est toujours la même
heure et c'est dresse on en fait quoi on
la donne soit en aliment sur animal soit
on en fait de la farine pour également
refaire des gâteaux où on en fait de
l'énergie et de nos groupes de
méthanisation donc le même produit
certes plusieurs fois et toujours seul
c'est le maître mot ah c'est le maître
mot c'est capital et on
a un terroir donc on peut produire et je
vois les lentilles que nous découvrons
finalement elles adorent puisque
elles sont très bonnes côté gustatives
et est un bien en cuisson donc elles
sont merveilleuse de façon vraiment à
découvrir donc on est certes un peu plus
cher que les notices de Canada mais il y
a rien à voir on pourrait y aller
d'autant plus que finalement ça
participe finalement à biodiversité
locale donc le fait d'avoir plus de
culture donc vis-à-vis des abeilles
vis-à-vis de tout ce qui est
bien fait pour l'environnement ça
profite à nous evinois et non pas au
Canadien donc on pourra découvrir bien
sûr l'huile de la plaine de Versailles
au salon de l'agriculture première
participation pour vous pourquoi il
participait pourquoi c'est intéressant
d'y aller oui c'est intéressant c'est
pour montrer notre gamme montrer ce
qu'on sait faire donc on est on est fier
des participer et un grand merci
finalement
au département des Yvelines et à la
région de nous accueillir sous le
pavillon Île-de-France qui aura qui sera
sur le allset du salon on le sait
pavillon Île-de-France vous y serez sur
quel jour j'y serai tous les jours sauf
le lundi et le mardi et vous lui ajoutez
quelque chose oui je vais rajouter autre
chose et on en profite pour lancer notre
site internet donc ça sera le samedi le
lancement officiel donc on a refait
notre site internet qui sera une
boutique en ligne où chaque consommateur
pourra finalement voir ce qu'on produit
comment on produit et éventuellement
acheter vous pouvez livrer directement
chez eux ce sera quoi le site internet
huile riz plein de versailles.fr et bien
le message est passé merci Christian
Hubert d'être venu en plateau et je vous
souhaite un très bon son de
l'agriculture donc vous serez présent
vous sur tout l'événement à qui se
tiendra du 25 février au 5 mars Porte de
Versailles à Paris merci d'être venu en
plateau et demain nous recevrons deux
apprentis bouchées qui participent à un
concours sur ce salon de l'agriculture
ne recevront également les délices du
potager à Feucherolles qui feront partie
aussi de ces représentants ivinois
nombreux très nombreux sur ce salon de
l'agriculture dans zone Europe samedi 25
février c'est un numéro spécial
enregistré à Europa expérience qui vous
sera proposé c'est un lieu pour
découvrir les institutions européennes
et leur fonctionnement Corentin lonsot
de nos confrères de radio sensation il y
a suivi des jeunes encadrés par la
Maison de l'Europe des Yvelines avant
leur départ en Erasmus l'occasion pour
eux d'en savoir un peu plus sur l'Union
européenne
principal c'était pour instaurer la paix
on apprend plus sur l'Union européenne
et voyager tout en restant à Paris c'est
possible tout au long du parcours les
visiteurs découvrent des installations
en réalité augmentée et même un cinéma à
360 degrés donc c'est un film de 8
minutes environ qui est quand on passe
en boucle ici en bas et c'est un film
qui parle un peu de l'histoire de
l'Europe pourquoi nous Européens on
s'est mis ensemble dans cette union
quelles sont les raisons et donc il y a
peu d'historique mais après il y a aussi
surtout aussi une partie sur sur les
défis futurs aussi pourquoi on doit
rester ensemble autre expérience
interactive cette carte au sol à l'aide
d'une tablette les visiteurs peuvent
réviser leur géographie et s'informer
sur divers projets européens partout sur
le continent donc aujourd'hui on est
avec des jeunes du programme Movin
organisé par la Maison de l'Europe c'est
des jeunes en insertion professionnelle
qui vont faire un stage
Erasmus a Dublin ou Malaga l'idée c'est
que
ils partent en ayant connaissance de qui
finance ce projet et donc l'Union
européenne les institutions et les
différents États membres comment
s'organise l'Union européenne et à quoi
elle sert avant de partir en mobilité en
Irlande et en Espagne ces jeunes
originaire des Yvelines ont pu en
apprendre plus sur les institutions et
sur les euros députés français
l'Union européenne a joué sur beaucoup
d'aspects que ce soit dans la société en
France mais dans tous les autres pays et
que ça c'était très important
on se rend pas compte forcément de
tout le spectre qui englobe l'Union
européenne outre Paris Strasbourg
Bruxelles Tallinn et Berlin ont déjà
leur repas expérience objectif pour lieu
ouvrir un espace de ce type dans chaque
capital européenne avant les prochaines
élections prévues en 2024
turn over dans le 7 8 avec changement de
visage en plateau et notamment Régine
rage qui nous a rejoint bonsoir Régine
de la rédaction de TV 78 alors comme
chaque semaine vous nous présentez une
école une formation du territoire c'est
dans le cadre de cette période de
formulation des vœux sur parcoursup et
aujourd'hui c'est au tour de l'IUT de
Rambouillet en tout cas l'une des
formations proposées à l'IUT de
Rambouillet
qui est tournée vers les métiers du
marketing et de la communication et en
plateau avec nous serin waglani et
mayssen Haïti bonsoir alors vous êtes
étudiante à l'IUT de Rambouillet et vous
avez récemment participé au concours
vidéo pour justement présenter votre
formation et pour aider les jeunes à
s'orienter dans leur parcours scolaire
je vous propose de regarder un extrait
toute la semaine mais tu peux aller en
attente tu fais trois jours en
entreprise et deux jours à l'école
franchement je trouve que l'idée qu'elle
m'a donné des filles c'est une très très
bonne idée le marketing digital c'est
une grande opportunité de nos jours et
surtout combien de parcours différents
bac ES bac S ou encore bac pro
allez on se motive
alors dans cette vidéo vous avez parlé
de la formation butc mais c'est quoi au
juste c'est une formation
pluridisciplinaire qui organisée autour
du marketing de la vente et de la
communication à la suite de ça vous
pouvez d'ailleurs occuper des postes
comme community manager donc on connaît
très bien sur les réseaux sociaux mais
aussi Trafic Manager donc c'est la
personne qui gère la mise en ligne des
campagnes publicitaires et alors du coup
ce cursus il peut se faire en initiale
et en alternance vous avez quatre choix
de parcours vous avez la stratégie de
marque événementiel le business
international le business développement
relation client et marketing digital
entrepreneuriat et e-business
de commercialisation c'est bien ça tu as
beaucoup de d'acronymes on a parlé d'IUT
de but d'ailleurs il y a une époque pas
si pas si lointaine on disait dut c'est
quoi la différence c'est la même chose
le dutbut totalement la même chose
justement il y a une réforme qui arrive
donc à partir de septembre prochain donc
actuellement il y a toujours les DUT et
on peut également faire une licence
professionnelle donc ça fait trois ans
au total mais il est débuté se faisait
sur deux ans et le buttc se fera sur
trois ans donc c'est le Bachelor
universitaire de technologie et comment
fait-on pour intégrer cette formation
alors cette formation elle est
accessible via parcoursup il faut avoir
bien évidemment un bon dossier il faut
faire un CV et une lettre de motivation
ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est qu'il
est on peut être issu en fait d'un bac
général technologique ou professionnel
alors Régine parler de ce concours
auquel vous avez participé pour
présenter votre formation pourquoi ça
vous tenait à coeur d'y participer
pourquoi le présenter de cette manière
là c'est assez original quand même de
présenter cette formation de cette
manière en vidéo en fait nous avons
voulu toucher le plus de jeunes on
savait que des de nombreux jeunes
regardez justement la téléréalité et
qu'avec l'humour forcément ça a l'air
intéressé beaucoup de jeunes on les
touche plus facilement avec ce type de
contenu
on a fait on a participé à ce concours
dans le cadre de notre formation au
préalable on a eu plusieurs cours
théoriques comment écrire un script les
différentes caméras pour les différentes
situations et on a pu mettre tout ça en
pratique justement en participant au
concours donc ça a été une belle
expérience qu'on a pu qu'on a pu
partager tous ensemble
à cette vidéo exactement c'est très
varié alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter un peu votre parcours on peut
commencer par vous mais il San alors moi
après l'obtention de mon baccalauréat
scientifique que j'ai eu avec mention
assez bien
j'étais assez perdue dans mes études
donc je savais pas
quel quel parcours j'allais entamer je
pense beaucoup de jeunes peuvent
se retrouver dans mon discours
j'ai choisi d'intégrer un BTS Gestion
des petites mailles d'entreprise ce qui
m'a permis de d'avoir une vision globale
de tous les corps métiers qu'on peut de
tous les corps de métiers qu'on peut
retrouver dans une entreprise donc que
ça soit ressources humaines de la
communication la relation client
fournisseurs le marketing du Market non
justement je n'avais pas vu marketing et
justement j'ai pu visualiser l'impact du
digital et j'ai voulu justement
apprendre toutes les techniques de
marketing mais
spécifiquement dans le monde du digital
suite au covid-19 j'ai pu
réaliser que
sans digital
on peut pas s'exonérer exactement
et pour vous votre parcours pour moi
alors j'ai fait un bac professionnel
vente
il faut savoir que c'est possible de
continuer de poursucer ses études après
un bac pro même si ça reste quand même
compliqué ensuite j'ai poursuivi avec un
BTS mdrc Négociation digitalisation de
la relation client donc il y avait déjà
de la digitalisation
on apprenait à utiliser WordPress à
animer des réseaux sociaux etc donc j'ai
pris la poursuite dite logique j'ai
poursuit j'ai poursuivi en licence
professionnelle e-commerce et marketing
numérique donc voilà différents parcours
qui permettent aussi de pouvoir arriver
à cette formation tout à fait justement
c'est des matières qu'on va retrouver
exactement dans le but TC l'an prochain
et justement quelles sont les matières
que vous apprenez aujourd'hui
alors c'est une formation
pluridisciplinaire donc c'est vraiment
très vaste et personnellement c'est ce
que j'aime dans cette formation c'est
que on va découvrir plein de choses et
on y voit principalement donc c'est
centré sur digital donc comment créer un
site internet comment le développer on a
pu voir du codage html et c'est
comment l'animer donc et toutes les
techniques de marketing qu'on va pouvoir
mettre en place au sein du site internet
exactement vous complétez on a aussi pu
faire du montage vidéo l'infographie de
la conduite de projets aussi et aussi on
nous sensibilise aux droits du numérique
tout ce qui est rgpd propriété
intellectuelle notamment
brevet des dessins et modèles etc donc
on est vraiment sensibilité
à tous les domaines qui touchent le
numérique oui c'est très actuel
exactement
justement quel est votre projet derrière
quel métier vous souhaiteriez exercer
toutes les deux pour ma part j'ai pour
objectif d'intégrer l'IAE Gustave Eiffel
pour pour le marketing pour un Master
Marketing
digitalie
exactement très bien et pour vous et moi
alors j'aimerais intégrer l'université
de Paris Nanterre pour le Master
information et communication parcours
flux de l'information et dossiers et
documents électroniques et pourquoi pas
plus tard devenir maître de conférences
il nous reste du temps juste pour une
question
de votre formation si vous deviez la
vendre comme vous l'avez fait dans la
vidéo mais si vous deviez la vendre à
noter les spectateurs c'est quoi le
point fort
personnellement je trouve beaucoup de
points forts mais pour moi le plus
impactant c'est le corps professionnel
on a eu la chance d'avoir des
professeurs qui des intervenants qui ont
créé leur propre entreprise
récemment une professeure qui a créé son
entreprise autour du digital pour pour
un cours sur le marketing plus
précisément sur les sur le mobile donc
c'est vraiment enrichissant d'une part
ils peuvent nous transmettre tout leur
savoir-faire et d'autre part on a des
situations concrètes c'est pas seulement
un cours enfin si c'est un court
théorique mais on retrouve beaucoup de
situations dans lequel on plonge et on
les captivé par le cours
si je puis si je peux ajouter alors en
fait on est totalement immergé dans le
monde du digital au sein de cette
formation
notamment la directrice de formation
nous fait faire plusieurs sorties
pédagogiques donc on va aller au salon
du marketing et on va visiter un
incubateur justement à Roubaix je crois
et découvrir une plateforme logistique
et bien merci d'avoir fait découvrir
cette formation but technique de
commercialisation merci à Céline merci
mais ça d'être venu en parlant rappelle
que vous êtes étudiante à l'IUT de
Rambouillet qui est rattaché à
l'Université Versailles 50 un petit tour
de table il y a aussi Céline Charle qui
est avec nous est-ce que vous utilisez
régulièrement un vélo dans votre
quotidien Céline pour venir à la
j'utilise le vélo mais plutôt en été ou
au printemps j'avoue qu'en hiver
pour les sorties pour moi c'est plutôt
les balades les sorties et c'est
vraiment printemps été pour vous les
sorties exactement à aussi réparer son
vélo soi-même et ce grâce à une
association qui est présente sur le
territoire 50 ans en Yvelines à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux c'est vicyclette
elle vous permet de d'apprendre à
réparer votre vélo et ce en plus à
moindre coût la dizaine de bénévoles de
l'association a reçu notre journaliste
Julien Leroy il a été initié au
changement de du câble de frein sur son
VTT et de quoi lui assurer une meilleure
sécurité sur la route regardez
bonjour à tous et ben voilà je suis
aujourd'hui avec mon vélo alors j'ai un
problème sur mon vélo parce que j'ai le
frein arrière qui est cassé et en fait
le problème c'est que j'en ai besoin
tous les jours pour aller travailler de
mon vélo pour aller à la rédaction alors
heureusement il existe les ateliers
bicyclette à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
l'objectif de l'association c'est de
vous former en fait à la réparation de
votre vélo vous êtes formé vous-même à
réparer votre vélo et on a rendez-vous
avec Benoît un bénévole de l'association
qui va nous expliquer comment réparer
tout ça et remettre le VTT sur pied
allez c'est parti
bonjour Benoît bonjour Julien merci de
merci beaucoup merci de nous recevoir
ici l'atelier bicyclette est-ce que du
coup vous pouvez peut-être m'expliquer
aussi quel est l'objectif de ces
ateliers l'objectif de l'atelier
vicyclette c'est de rendre les gens
autonomes effectivement sur leur vélo de
leur proposer un atelier de réparation
chose qu'ils ont pas forcément chez eux
et de les rendre autonome pour réparer
leur vélo dès qu'il y a une petite
réparation une maintenance à faire
dessus qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
réparer ici ce que tout est réparable
déjà et alors tout est réparable pas
forcément mais toutes les réparations
standard sur un vélo que soit frein ou
transmission on peut vraiment faire tout
ça sur le vélo effectivement si le cadre
va commencer à être cassé ça ça atteint
les limites de réparation qu'on peut
faire mais sinon pour la maintenance
globale du vélo on peut vraiment tout
faire ici alors justement aujourd'hui
Benoît j'ai un problème avec mon frein
du coup mon frein arrière et il est
sectionné effectivement je crois qu'il
est en fin de vie
je sais pas si possible de faire quelque
chose oui on va s'occuper de ça super et
bah c'est parti
tu ne fais que le dessert il y a pas
besoin de le dévisser complètement
d'accord
on va sortir tout le câble et
je pense
[Musique]
que ça veut dire
tu dois quand même le glisser ici de
toute façon donc là je l'ai passé là et
je le glisse à travers le
[Musique]
bon maintenant ce qu'on va vérifier donc
normalement ça va pas du changer mais
que tes patins soient bien parallèles
[Musique]
je ferai d'abord desserrer 5 mois
donc là ce que je vous donne
tu peux y aller
juste dessous ça doit pouvoir se coincer
ah oui c'est juste oui d'accord
[Musique]
on l'a pas testé mais on a vu que ça a
frottait pas et que non c'est super ça
va me sauver la vie franchement ça
devrait beaucoup mieux marché et ben
voilà mon vélo freine de nouveau
parfaitement je suis super content alors
pour l'adhésion sachez que c'est 10
euros par an et par personne et c'est 18
euros si vous êtes une famille vous
allez pouvoir retrouver tous les
renseignements sur le site internet de
bicyclette quant à moi je reprends la
route donc une bonne route à tous à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
bravo bravo à Julien alors comme chaque
mercredi notre parti dédiée au 7e art au
cinéma et d'abord le coup de cœur d'un
réalisateur yvelinois pour découvrir ou
redécouvrir un classique du cinéma si je
vous dis docteur patch est-ce que ça
vous évoque quelque chose en plateau a
priori non à ma droite sur la gauche je
crois qu'il y a l'acteur Robin Williams
effectivement c'est un film sorti en
1998 réalisé par Tom Chadia qui avait au
casting Robin Williams et cette semaine
c'est le coup de cœur de notre
réalisateur yvelinois Gauthier Bara
[Musique]
docteur patch en 1998 réalisé par Tom
chadiaq nous sommes avec l'acteur Robin
Williams sur un scénario qui est une
histoire vraie une histoire vraie d'un
médecin en fait qui a donné sens au Rire
Médecin au nez rouge tout simplement le
clown dans les hôpitaux ici donc Robin
Williams interprète donc ce fameux
docteur patch et c'est un
adulte qui sort d'hôpital psychiatrique
et qui va vouloir donner sens à sa vie
en voyant qui peut faire rire les
enfants dans les hôpitaux qu'on peut
traiter en fait
des maladies graves joyeusement de façon
drôle humoristique
[Musique]
et il va se battre pour ça en première
année on n'a pas le droit d'aller en
pratique dans les écoles de médecine et
lui il va s'incruster il va forcer le
destin et voir qu'il y a une autre
médecine qui peut se créer une médecine
aussi qui peut être là pour les
personnes qui n'ont pas les moyens de se
faire soigner donc ce film est basé
là-dessus plein d'émotions du mot et de
tendresse avec plus de simplicité de
l'acteur Robin Williams on peut parler
du coup de poésie et c'est un véritable
film qui fait sourire
[Musique]
génial avec un acteur génial Robin
Williams c'est un moment il m'a fait
beaucoup rire dans hook dans Madame
dopfire voilà c'est des souvenirs
d'enfance qui remontent et merci à
Gauthier Bara pour cette redécouverte du
film docteur patch alors comme tous les
mercredis cette partie cinéma se
poursuit avec vous Céline Charles on va
faire le point sur l'actualité c'est
sorti ciné de la semaine le premier film
que vous nous proposez ce soir c'est
bien sûr le nouveau film de Steven
Spielberg évidemment on aurait pu croire
qu'après 76 ans et presque 40 longs
métrages le réalisateur américain aurait
déjà tout raconté et bien non il nous
prouve le contraire avec son nouveau
film The Fabel man après James gredin
Armageddon time c'est à son tour de
livrer une partie de sa vie regardez si
tu arrêtes de faire des films ta mère
sera un consolable je suis perdu je sais
plus quoi faire fais ce que ton cœur te
donne
[Musique]
est-ce que tu as préféré
alors comme on vient de le voir le
réalisateur de ity ou bien Jurassic Park
mais en scène dans ce nouveau film sa
propre enfance et sa propre adolescence
dans l'Amérique moyenne des années 50 et
60 il y aborde sa passion dévorante pour
le cinéma sa relation parfois
conflictuelle avec une famille autant
couleur et sa vie d'adolescents avec ses
hauts et ses bas un film touchant et
plein de vie où on apprend vraiment à
découvrir comment Steven est devenu
Spielberg finalement pendant son enfance
on continue cette sélection avec un
drame romantique oui ça s'appelle arrête
avec tes mensonges de Olivier Peillon
c'est une adaptation du livre à succès
éponyme de Philippe Besson on y retrouve
Guillaume de Tonquédec dans le rôle de
Stéphane Bellecour un romancier qui
accepte de retourner dans sa ville
natale pour y parrainer un événement
après avoir juré de ne jamais y
retourner il va rencontrer Lucas
interpréter par le petit-fils de
Jean-Paul Belmondo Victor Belmondo Lucas
est le fils de Thomas qui n'est autre
que le premier amour de Stéphane le
romancier alors qu'il n'avait que 17 ans
regardez
il fait comment mon père
[Applaudissements]
et toi aussi
[Musique]
seule fois aussi lumineux à la télé
c'était qui pour vous
abandonné du jour au lendemain comme
pour toi sans un mot sans une
explication et dans ce film on va donc
se plonger dans les souvenirs de cette
histoire d'amour avorter mais jamais
oublier une adaptation autobiographie
autobiographique qui je suis sûre vous
fera vous émouvoir
Belmondo effectivement le portrait
quasiment craché mais en tout cas et
ressemblance avec Jean-Paul Belmondo on
va terminer avec un documentaire et oui
Grégory je vous propose un documentaire
pour clore cette sélection documentaire
animalier pour être plus précise les
gardiennes de la planète du réalisateur
Jean Albert lièvre nous compte la vie et
l'histoire des baleines et plus
particulièrement leur chant un système
de communication unique au monde alors
le documentaire est très immersif il
nous plonge vraiment dans l'eau aux
côtés des cétacés les images comme on
peut le voir sont saisissantes et je
pense que c'est d'ailleurs plus
grandiose sur écran de cinéma le film a
évidemment un enjeu écologique en toile
de fond il a l'alerte mais toujours avec
optimisme sur la faune essentielle à
notre survie que l'on est partiellement
en train de détruire petit plus ce
documentaire est raconté par un
yvelinois un certain Jean Dujardin
moi personnellement ça sera le nouveau
Steven Spielberg vous avez fait votre
choix
arrête avec tes mensonges
franchement oui ça pourrait nous
intéresser du coup le documentaire c'est
ça exactement
s'il y a un film à sélectionner les
images et l'esthétique il a donné un
côté vraiment poétique en fait c'est les
baleines qui racontent l'histoire la
voix de voilà de Jean Dujardin donc je
pense que ça peut être très immersif
d'être en plus ça a été pris au 4 coins
du monde dans plusieurs pays on est
vraiment dans l'eau donc c'est
passionnant je pense à découvrir à ne
pas manquer cette semaine merci Céline
pour cette sélection avant de se quitter
un dernier coup d'oeil à la météo de
demain
et après les belles images de la
grisaille malheureusement demain matin
dans les Yvelines il fera à 7 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie à 6 degrés à Houdan et
Versailles c'est un peu plus doux dans
le sud du département avec 8 degrés à
Rambouillet Rambouillet ou quelques
gouttes de pluie sont attendues dans
l'après-midi au contraire du reste du
territoire où on pourrait apercevoir
quelques éclairs six côtés température 9
degrés dans la partie centrée sud des
Yvelines 10 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et
ce jeudi 23 février c'est la Saint
Lazare voilà c'est la fin de ce 7 8
merci de votre fidélité et demain vous
retrouverez Mathilde Franco à la
présentation d'une nouvelle édition
belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]